[Music]
can't believe we're doing this
i never thought i'd get you out of the
city
i think this is gonna be the perfect
place to work without distraction
i've been coming out here to write for a
few years now this place inspires us
i could really use some of the
inspiration you guys have on tap
i'm facing some serious writer's block
that won't last long trust me
something weird is going on here and i
want to know what it is
there's nothing more addictive than
success you tasted it now
you're never going to be able to live
without it
[Music]
we are not safe
[Applause]
i'm trying to keep this family together
under very difficult circumstances
[Music]
this is hawkins
i know the worst thing that's ever
happened here in the four years i've
been working here
[Music]
it was when an owl attacked eleanor
gillespie's head because he thought that
her hair was a nest
[Music]
[Applause]
99 out of 100 times kid goes missing the
kid is with a parent or relative
what about the other time
what you said 99 out of a hundred what
about the other time the one
wow
[Music]
[Music]
i think she knows what happened to her
[Music]
and the girl
[Music]
she can't have gone far
[Music]
what the hell
you know will
do you know where he is
hiding
from who
maybe will
saw something that he shouldn't have
what is it
bad memories
of what
alexandra's our home
what we have
it's rare
if we live we live for them
we gotta get through this together
if we die we die for them
[Applause]
i don't leave anybody behind not ever
do you want to talk about it
we need to start thinking about other
options
always andrea needs us
it's everything we have
so
you're leaving to fight ghosts this is a
path you don't want to go down
dumb worse
these people
they want stuff
[Applause]
that is what's out there
don't be scared not a lot
god isn't here anymore
this
is a death march
and you are the damn pied piper
the paranoid
but i'm right
lost something
and i don't think it's a bad thing that
it did
i did what needed to be done
you destroyed everything that we built
the only way this works is if we trust
each other
so what do you say
if you say trust him
i'll trust him
the woman who lived is not the one
standing here now
so keep pushing me
please
[Music]
[Applause]
hello
i'm lance hornsby welcome to the
commonwealth
into every generation a slayer is born
she alone will stand against the
vampires
the demons and the forces of darkness
one girl in all the world a chosen one
i don't know what's coming next
and in the end it's gonna be us
the earth is definitely doomed
i just can't believe it's back the brand
new sunnydale high school being rebuilt
it means something as in what
you brought me here i thought it was to
kill me do you want to be punished i
want to be a willow we all are who are
no matter how much we may appear to have
changed spike i wanted to give you what
you deserve
and i got it
your soul now all it does
is burn
spike is here because i want him here we
need him
you faced the monster inside of you and
you fought back
i believe in you spike
sorry to bargin i'm afraid we have a
slight apocalypse
they're all slayers potential slaves
waiting for one to be called and they're
all the know where to sunnydale you're
here from beneath you it devours
there's evil then there's the thing that
created evil
first the first is unlike anything we
face it only appears in the guise of
someone who's passed away
put the bananas if we all do our parts
we'll be the ones left standing
trying to turn a bunch of little girls
into an army it's pretty radical
baby i need a spike that's dangerous i'm
sorry
force yourself to do what can't be done
or else we are not an army it takes more
than browsing speeches to leave if
you're going to be a general you need to
be able to make difficult decisions
regardless of cost i am my humble
servant the slayer the strongest the
fastest
so what else you got
deflector shields deflector shields off
to win this war to save the world
it's about power
are you ready to finish this
[Music]
we're on the verge of war i
you don't know when it'll come you can't
run
can't hide can't pretend it's not the
end because it is
they want an apocalypse oh we'll get one
one there's only one thing on this earth
more powerful than evil and that's us
great things are happening and you're
gonna see the glory i will end you
when i say i love you it's not because i
want you
i love what you are
what you do
how you try
[Music]
he's a vampire okay skilled with powers
no human could possibly excuse me
i think i'm stuck
now i want you two to get good rest
what if i have a bad dream
i'm sure we can handle any dream you
have
what if i dream that you sent us away
into the dark and we get hurt
really hurt
and what if i'm so sad
and scared of the dark out there
that i put poison in me
for years and years
until my blood turns into poison
and my heart breaks right in half and i
can't feel anything happy
ellie can't stand it anymore and i i
have to die
until i'm on a silver table
it's my jaw wired shut
would you wake us up
from a dream like that
we're not like any other family
we're different
because of where we grew up
hill house
your mother she was not crazy
neither was your sister neither is your
brother neither are you
it's that house
[Applause]
you don't have to worry now sweetie
that really bad dream
of course i'd wake you
just let me have just one beard tonight
jesus what the hell is this music man i
cannot wait to get the hell out of this
kodunk town well make sure you do them
before it's too late because every year
you wait you just get more and more
stuck here believe me i know she know
what i was thinking that's weird i'll
get you all some ketchup
don't you do that about me
guess what happened tonight you got a
date um
no
a vampire came into the bar you know how
many people are having sex with vampires
these days you would be surprised people
you know sometimes those people
disappear
apparently there's this vampire bar in
tree fort fantasia
fang tasia
he set up a date with a vampire what do
you have a death wish
you look like vampire bait so are you
saying you think i look nice vampires
think about one thing and one thing on
drinking your blood i think we need to
stop seeing each other
what are you i told you
[Music]
do you believe there is a demi mom
a half world between what we know and
what we fear
the place in the shadows
rarely seen but deeply felt
where some unfortunate souls are cursed
to live always
that sounds like a warning
it's an invitation
[Applause]
where is your master
right behind you
[Music]
they're coming to get you barbara uh
the only person you're gonna scare is
yourself
[Music]
gotcha
good night harvey
can i
[Music]
in the town of greendale where it always
feels like halloween
there lived a girl who was half witch
half mortal who on her 16th birthday
would have to choose between two worlds
the witch world of her family and the
human world of her friends
[Music]
are you willing to forsake the path of
light
you must
i shall remember sabrina
you're going to die half breed
girls girls let's not be catty [ __ ]
[Music]
i'm not an evil person
but these are desperate times
[Music]
my name is sabrina spellman
and i will not
sign it away
would you like to do the honors with
pleasure
rise
rise
[Music]
was on hilda she annoyed me so i killed
her and buried her in the yard
[Music]
what do you want kid
it's about my dad
i want you to hurt him
you know it's a sin just ask me that
i know
people said before you were a preacher
you did things
how far it will go
problem is your daddy's a big fella he's
gonna fight back
things will escalate that's what these
things do they escalate
and violence
makes violence
makes nothing much at all
preacher enough almost done sheriff
is that what you want kid
[Music]
jesus what kind of a preacher are you
[Music]
magic swirls all around us
it is in the air that we breathe
do not be so naive as to think we are
the only ones who can harness its power
nothing is as it says congratulations on
your acceptance to belgrave university
we have a question what do you know
about the hermetic or the blue rose
everyone knows the order is fake news
[Music]
you're about to start the biggest
adventure of your lives
[Music]
it appears you've been summoned
will you heed the call
yes
we'll be expecting great things from you
welcome to the order i'm going to teach
you how to use magic properly a tutor
you got stuck with me for some reason
just lucky i guess
there is a creature out there
that is tearing apart our recruits
this is the most powerful incantation
ever created
what is it too anything is possible
if you don't do something people are
gonna die
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we will build a world like you have
never seen
this is what you signed up for
[Music]
all magic has a cost
if you don't pay the price things would
go
as it wrong
[Music]
[Music]
you